mein name ist nun kommt meine lieben
freunde werden mal wieder gemeinsam
unsere gehirnzellen vernichten denn wir
reagieren heute gemeinsam auf die folge
schweinerei meine freundin hat mich
durch ein mini schweine ersetzt
ich glaube jeder weiß um welche serie
sich auch heute wieder handeln wird hilf
mir
bevor wir uns nun die folge gemeinsam
anschauen würde ich sagen werfen wir
zuvor einen blick in die kommentare das
schwein hatte noch die beste
schauspielleistung wessen greenshoe
meter kocht auch gerade das schwein ist
geiler als der mann nutze diesen
kommentar als bruder muss los button ich
rufe die peter an ich würde diese
schweinebraten ja da wissen wir
wahrscheinlich abgeben wir in der folge
daher würde ich sagen schon lange alles
wir fangen direkt an
[Musik]
ich sagte erstmal minischwein meinten
die ein kleines plastik schweinchen oder
ein stofftier oder so aber nein es ist
halt ein wirklich lebendige schweinchen
dass mainz nicht ernst ich hatte doch
die rufnummer lisbeth ja die habe ich
verkauft und davon habe ich eben geholt
ja also wenn die oma nur vererbt dann
wünscht sie sich bestimmt auch dass das
geld dann für ein hausschwein namens
egon ausgegeben wird zumal seit drei
monaten haben wir jetzt wieder den job
wir sind froh dass wir die runden kommen
hast du es braucht euch da etwas das
viel fitter aufwand macht wo schläft das
was gibt's zu fressen
denn diesen dreckig ohne ende also man
merkt direkt dass die frau die von dem
schweine richtig begeistert ist und der
mann der makler noch nicht so richtig
man muss allerdings sagen das
hausschwein oder allgemeinen schweine
mit dirigentin und ich kann nicht mehr
fort intelligent aussprechen schweine
sind wirklich sauer intelligente tiere
und überhaupt nicht dreckig und sehr
stubenrein und keine ahnung was er mich
kann es bezeugen ich wohne mit jude
zusammen
wer also wirklich so kleine mini schwein
als haustiere finde ich mega cool also
real tag aber wir schauen wir wie es
weitergeht so süß doch auch schon das
ätherische öl natürlich mit ihrem mann
absprechen müssen den stellte ruth
marquardt ist eine systemische beraterin
es ist eine systemische beraterin das
ist als die gut versichert ich zu sagen
und dann aber wirklich jetzt feiert ja
ich meine hat er gerade wirklich gesagt
schwein gehabt schwanger sind wir eine
schweinerei ein paar tage später matches
man ist wieder auf montage die 26
jährige lenkt sich mit hausschwein egon
sie lenkt sich
mit einem stein ab na gut ich mache mir
immer noch bei hilf mir nichts was
eigentlich wollte carney
wie ist das auto schweine shampoo hat
sich extra view ist ab märz verständigt
oder lukas kann das sein irgendwie des
benutzers bekommen es hat sich erfreut
mit dem schweinitzer boulevard hilft mir
einfach dass startest du mir jetzt ein
scheiß auspressen was sowieso nicht hier
war mein stil ist irgendwie als auch
mein alltag nehmen zu können ist kann er
mich am arsch vorbeigehen
aber ich schaue jetzt ein shampoo
waschen von unten schweine shampoo
nehmen wir das in sack gehen willst du
dass deine baustelle verschwindest keine
lust drauf
gehörig
stehen und nicht in der kiste ich lasse
mir nicht von meinem mann vorschreiben
was ich zu tun zu lassen haben
vor allem nicht wenn es sowieso nie zu
hause sie hat sogar ein tattoo das ist
mein leben
also davon krise wirklich von mir den
gewinn der wo kriegt jetzt erst recht
seien schweine shampoo und den
kuscheligen bademantel auch noch und es
besteht jetzt sofort im internet ja
finde ich auch richtig
der mann arbeitet und die frau bestellt
schweine stammkunden bademantel für
aegon
ich hasse das wenn man nichts muss er
comics kennt ihr das schreibt zwar in
die kommentare
oder vielleicht der einzige hengst du
noch sauber was soll der ganze krempel
hier
wieso hat diese schweiz und dem ich es
heißt mein gott was mit lukas warum sind
die rolle des man darunter hatte auch
keine schule oder das hat er bestimmten
hayden colin kostet du weißt ganz genau
dass wir kein geld haben und du schmeißt
einfach zum fenster raus mir scheint
aber auch dass thomas und seine frau
über ein ganz anderes thema sprechen
müssten nämlich wer hat die macht er in
die aktion der bringt das geld rein
lieblos verwendet die sprechen nicht
über die wirklichen themen das ist aber
auch relativ typisch für partition froh
dass wir dann so eine professionelle
meinung und immer noch einholen können
von der frau angela merkel hier
da freue ich mich wirklich überhaupt das
ist da fühlt man sich so die direkten
sicheren steht das schwein jetzt an
erster stelle
oder war es tut mir leid ich habe keinen
eingekauft hat gestern die letzte
bekommen
ist ok jacobs ist es okay kannst du das
bitte mal auf sein so über ihn zu reden
glaubst du keine gefühle stürzten gegen
egon taktik ganz macht vom einen turm
geworden
sie sind große stars bestätigt das doch
nur hallo gast kinos er ist ein beben
der kanal nicht allein schaffen wer
braucht noch bevor ich weiß nicht wie
jeder das ganze gerade hier also kahler
betrachter beobachtet aber ich sehe
wirklich bei jedem im grund zum böse
sein ich meine sie ist halt die ganze
zeit alleine und jemand ist immer auf
der arbeit auf der anderen seite
verdient ihr mann alt das geld und ist
halt zu recht auf der arbeit weil er
dort halt arbeiten muss und wenn der so
natürlich vernachlässigt wird aufgrund
der schweiz ist es natürlich nicht
und da muss die beziehung auf jeden fall
dran arbeiten und eigentlich könnte ich
da auch als therapeut eingestellt werden
oder ich fahre nicht jetzt zur schule
[Musik]
habt ihr es gehört
er macht dieses schwein in mein bett
wieso hat wein zu egal oder rage erhält
wieso hast du dir der nicht gewinnt dann
kannst du das mal verraten hat sie nun
ein bisschen durchfallen zeigte gleich
mal was durch verlädt gleich was durch
bilder die jetzt anpacken erwartet dass
hilfen also so abwegig ist es jetzt
eigentlich nicht reich mir langsam ja
nicht irgendwo schwanger das ist mein
weg wenn menschen vielleicht auf eine
unbewusste art und weise gar keine nähe
mehr mit ihrem partner haben will dann
ist das schwein im bett natürlich der
einfachste weg um den mann aus dem
schlafzimmer zu treiben generell sind
getrennte schlafzimmer und zwar nichts
schlechtes die können das liebesleben
bereichern aber nicht wenn ein
streitpunkt zwischen beiden partnern
steht ich muss gleich wieder aufstehen
ein paar stunden ich muss mich auch
bosch diskutieren ich muss morgen auf
das fahrrad für lukas abnehmen ich weiß
nicht das bezahlen soll das beschert uns
abgeholt
das fahrrad für lukas mir scheiß egal
hauptsache das schwein in windel und ein
bett ihres ich muss mich auf jeden
morgen an der kasse bedienen unsere
haushaltskasse sonst ja keine ahnung
ja du vielleicht kann ich das auch
einfach abholen kann es noch ein
bisschen kleinerer ganz nett gescheitert
ist auf den namen huber zurück
reservieren
du musst ja ja nicht wieder meine ruhe
denn ich muss gut habt ihr das geklärt
zum glück ist das geld aus der
haushaltskasse bestimmt gar nicht für
die ganzen sachen für schwein
draufgegangen das brauche ich denn cola
und es ist ja nichts mehr da auch die
haushaltskasse ist leer
das moral von der geschicht rachel ist
ein bösewicht ja last lag dabei bei der
unter dem video wendet wenn ihr denkt
dass ich cool bin ansonsten heutiges
video und die wii action auf die hilfe
der folge mit dem schweinchen jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wie bereits
gesagt wenn euch gefallen da will ich
mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch hier unter dem video hier freunde
schreiben in die kommentare
ob ich eventuell auf den zweiten teil
hiervon also auf das ganze wie es
weitergeht mit dem schweinchen in einer
woche reagieren sollen oder solche auf
ein anderes video reagieren dann
schreibt das auch gerne unten in die
kommentare abonniert main kanals noch
kein teil der luxus sei dadurch
verpasste keine videos mehr und falschen
abonnent würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr auf die glocke klicken würdet dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
ein neues video online geht
[Musik]